du théâtre off d'avignon au cinéma
d'hollywood il ya effectivement un pas
de géant avec un invité prestigieux
d'antenne 2010 et richard widmark
bienvenue monsieur widmark bienvenue
alors pour la majorité des français vous
êtes l'inspecteur madigan dans une série
télévisée très très connu pour tous les
cinéphiles vous êtes surtout l'un des
grands du cinéma américain je cite
quelques-uns de vos films la dernière
rafale les forbans de la nuit et
justement ce film les forbans de la nuit
va être projeté à cannes dans deux jours
vendredi prochain vendredi soir entrée
gratuite d'ailleurs au palais des
festivals pour tous les amateurs fait au
cours de l'hommage du cinéma américain à
cannes 4e année consécutive de cet
hommage au cinéma américain richard
widmark combien avez vous tourné deux
films pas exactement surge en effet 75
ans vit 60
je les ai pas tous content et je croise
lesquels avril 75
est-ce que vous tournez encore beaucoup
et s mais de temps en temps le dernier
c'était un film pour la télé qui
s'appelait il était une fois au texas
que j'ai fait à l'automne dernier mais
il ya trois quatre semaines j'ai été
invité à dîner à cannes et au festival
j'ai accepté l'invitation et puis donc
j'accepte se rendre pour une invitation
à dîner c'est très loin
enfin j'aime tellement la france que
j'accepte toujours ce genre d'invitation
vous n'avez pas tourné avec des
réalisateurs français n'ont alors non je
ne pense pas non
en revanche vous avez tourné avec un
allemand volker schlöndorff jan dau
dernier film c'était colère en louisiane
vont que jean-louis vainqueur thunder
oui c'est un super de metteur en scène
j'étais ici à l'automne dernier
d'ailleurs je parlais de ce film
policier à la télévision ça plaît
revente de ces avis c'était un signe
tout à fait intéressant alors on va voir
tout de suite un extrait de ce film si
vous voulez bien
extrait donc de colère en louisiane avec
shauna omar bongo quant au choix de m
mais tout est cher anthony m
la ronde jonchant 8 2 m et mme pilote
olé richard widmark vous avez fait
beaucoup de western dans votre carrière
on a l'impression qu'on ne tourne plus
de western maintenant c'est vrai on ne
fait pas tellement le temps en temps
quand même
mais cette époque était terminée je
crois que c'est rien du star wars ce
qu'on fait willis et des grandes
productions du genre star wars remplacer
ouest et est de nouveau truc
les gamins s'ennuie manon dans les
westerns c'est un truc un peu vieux jeu
ils préfèrent les choses un peu plus
moderne plus science fiction avec tous
les gadgets qu'on trouve dans ce genre
de film il aime beaucoup plus vous êtes
certainement l'un de ceux qui connaît le
mieux hollywood
j'imaginais ce qu'hollywood a vraiment
beaucoup changé au cours de ces
dernières années on a parlé d'une vraie
crise à hollywood et que ça a changé par
rapport à l'époque où j'y travaille et
maintenant j'y vais plus tellement donc
je sais pas trop ce qui s'y passe
j'habille et à santa barbara en
californie
mais je ne sais pas trop ce qu'est la
nouvelle vague de livres je sais que les
choses ont quand même changé mais enfin
je sais que c'est différent de l'époque
peut-être que ça s'est amélioré mais
enfin je ne pourrais pas vous dire tout
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que c'est
différent alors pour moi ça me plaît
moins alors pour terminer richard
widmark ya une chose que les gens savent
moins c'est que vous avez fait des
études de sciences politiques et vous
avez toujours été très violemment contre
le président reagan je crois
effectivement j'ai fait des sciences po
à l'université c'était d'ailleurs là
dedans que j'ai fais j'ai connu reggane
dans sept premiers jours mais j'étais
pas un admirateur en tout cas ça c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire je ne
partageais pas son opinion et ses
principes
donc actuellement je suis disons de
l'autre côté de la barrière pour ce qui
est des élections je voterai contre
vegan contre le parti républicain pour
te dire que je traîne en crise ça y est
vous avez peu de choix du bailleur merci
beaucoup merci richard widmark merci
donc je rappelle que l'hommage à richard
widmark et à tout ce cinéma où il marqua
tout le cinéma américain ce sera
vendredi soir au palais des festivals à
cannes voilà fin de cette édition du
journal tout de suite le rendez-vous de
la météo complète avec laurent cabrol et
puis le prochain rendez-vous est
l'information ce sera le journal
20 heures daniel bilalian excellente
après-midi bonne soirée sur antenne 2
ma